i got to tell you marianne did the
greatest thing
she sent me a cameo i loved it
she sent me a cameo from dr now from 600
pound life
oh would you pay for that 200 yep and it
was worth
every penny and i pay more for you
because i love you so much and i don't
know imagine this is
200 bucks hey howard i hope you're doing
well in staying safe
i have a message booked by love marianne
from brooklyn she says
over 35 years you have been a staple in
our life
you kept us saying during this pandemic
41 days to 66m
contract and your fans are praying that
you will
stay just a little bit longer
please please stay that you well
and that's all she needs
and howard if you say another five years
i'll send you a copy of my book how
would best of luck to you
and i think if you say your fan will be
delighted howard
take care of yourself this guy's got
charisma coming out of his ass i mean
i don't understand something he's a
doctor
he operates on people and he has time
for cameo
call me old school i don't want my
doctor doing cameos i just don't
know you know what i mean i want him to
maintain a professionalism i mean but
he's taking home the doubt
oh my god i have a message booked by
love
marianne from take two
there's no such thing as a bad take with
this guy oh no he's got surgeries to do
he doesn't have time for tank terror
doctor now
i love the guy yeah but he shouldn't be
reading messages
i yes stick with your strong suit this
is
all wrong it sounds all wrong to me